good morning everyone I speak for the
entire university
is a deep honor and a very sincere
pleasure to welcome to Ansan suchi chair
of the National League of democracy in
Burma a member of parliament to Yale it
is just a very special privilege for us
to have you with us I believe that
everyone in this audience knows the
basic outline of da souza extraordinary
story the daughter of Aung San who
liberated Burma from colonial rule
before being cruelly assassinated in
1947 she spent many years outside Burma
being educated at Oxford and raising a
family there when her mother became very
ill she returned to Burma in 1988 only
to find that a student uprising was
restoring some sense of hope to the
millions of Burmese under oppressive
military rule she quickly became the
leader of the movement for democracy
assuming the mantle with humility
bravery and courage she famously defied
soldiers whose loaded guns were aimed
directly at her inspiring the u2 song
walk on she was placed under house
arrest soon thereafter and spent more
than 15 of the next 20 years in
isolation released from house arrest in
November 2010 an elected to parliament
in April of this year she has continued
her crusade for the rights of the
Burmese people thanks to dawsons courage
and the inspiration she is provided to
the people of Burma the prospects for
the restoration of democracy are greater
now than they have been for decades
since her release from house arrest
dosoo has partnered with Burma's new
civilian government to help lead a
period of rapid rapid political and
economic liberalization the government
has released hundreds of political
prisoners and granted substantial
freedom to the press the United States
and many other nations have reciprocated
these actions by easing sanctions and
pledging foreign aid
but because a democratic future is not
fully assured doses work is not yet done
thus who was honored with the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1991 and with a
congressional gold medal last week Jane
and I had the privilege of hearing her
less speak last Friday when she received
a global citizen award from the Atlantic
Council as you will see momentarily she
is a true inspiration in a beautiful
essay that Dawson wrote in 1990 entitled
freedom from fear she claimed that Nehru
naraz words describing Mahatma Gandhi
could be applied to her father on Sam I
would suggest that they apply equally
well to her and I paraphrase here to get
the gender right the essence of her
teaching is fearlessness and truth and
action elide to these always keeping the
welfare of the masses in view as she
herself has said about the poetry that
she Revere's and from which she takes
strength dosoo is and I quote a great
unifier that knows no frontiers of space
or time today I'm pleased to announce
that Yale is taking several small steps
to facilitate the reforms underway in
Burma first we are stepping up our
admissions recruitment efforts for
students from Burma and we will be
communicating more broadly the fact
little known there that the parents of
applicants to Yale College who make less
than 65 thousand dollars a year are not
required to make a contribution to their
child's tuition second we will work to
implement an idea discussed yesterday
with josue to bring high school teachers
and principals to Yale to encourage them
to raise the sights of their students to
advise them and to advise them on the
generous financial aid programs
available at Yale and elsewhere in the
United States and finally I'm
particularly pleased to announce that
with the cooperation of the
Council on Southeast Asian Studies at
Yale we will support the establishment
of a successor publication to the
Journal of the Burma Research Society a
prominent vehicle for scholarly
publication on Burma before it was shut
down by the military regime in the 1970s
as a Dean brensa mentioned to you the
chub Fellowship is among the highest
honors accorded to a visitor at Yale
since nineteen forty nine chub fellows
have included former presidents of the
United States numerous heads of state
and prominent figures from government
industry and the arts today's chub
fellow adds luster to that luminous list
please join me in welcoming long San
thank you thank you for a very warm
welcome the subject on which I'm going
to speak today is rule of law not rule
of law as you might be taught in your
classrooms that your professors can do
far more competently than I could ever
hope to but rule of law as I see it and
others like me in Burma see it and why
rule of law is important to us to begin
with I had a very healthy minimum
contact with the law until nineteen
eighty-eight up to nineteen eighty-eight
the only two contacts shall we say I had
had with the law whereas a student at
Oxford once I was cycling the wrong way
down a one-way street and ran straight
into a police patrol car the policeman
put out his head and looked at me and
asked me if I knew that that was a
one-way street I said yes so he
proceeded on his way and I hopped off my
bike and proceeded on mine the second
time also was at Oxford when at an
artist before dusk and the roads were
empty I cycled absent-mindedly through a
red light and the roads were empty but
for a patrol car which is right behind
him so I should have known then that my
contacts of the security forces were
going to be unique in future the real
contact came in 1988-89 when I was first
placed under house arrest this was on
the 20th July 1989 and suddenly hordes
of policemen and uniformed soldiers came
into my compound and rounded up
everybody there I was kept in the house
I thought they were going to take away
take me away to prison as well but they
left me in the house and the house
arrest and took the others way to prison
they had brought a detention order and
they raided art this order said
that actor they were they were placing
me under house arrest in accordance with
the law meant to how did they put it to
protect the state against destructive
elements I was a destructive element so
this meant that I could be placed under
house arrest without trial now this is
section 10 section 10 is has two parts
10a and 10b 10a means imprisonment
without trial 10 B is house arrest
without trial I was placed at a house
arrest and a 10 B according to that law
the detention order would have to be
renewed every six months and was
renewable for a total period of three
years and the decision as to whether or
not they would renew the detention order
would be made by what they call the the
central committee of Ministers this is a
small group of three or four ministers
including the Home Minister at that time
I had had so very little to do with such
matters that I had assumed that they had
placed me under house arrest because
this was in accordance with law they I
was alone in the house my two sons were
with me for a short while but then they
left to go back to England but they kept
me in the house and the security forces
took up their residence in my compound I
thought also then that this was what
they were entitled to do it was only
years later I learned that they were not
entitled to take up residence within my
compound so this is the beginning of the
time when I realized how very little I
knew about the laws of the land and how
very little I knew about whether or not
these laws were respected I was allowed
a shortwave radio which get me in touch
with outside world and I learned from
this ray
that more and more of the members of my
party were been arrested and most often
they were arrested under section 5
section 5 is the law that was brought
out in 1950 to cope with the what they
called emergency emergency situation of
that time because there were many
insurgencies then and in under Section 5
we used to the later we politicians
politicians who's who refer to it as I
can't bear you law anybody that they
didn't like they could grab under
Section five and put them away for a
period of up to five years but they
would slap other charges against these
people and could give them up to 20
years which they have done I think our
longest member of our party who served
the longest single period in jail stayed
there for 18 years and three months
although he was originally supposed to
have been imprisoned only for about five
years so my own experiences made me
understand that there was no rule of law
in Burma the law was used by those in
authority for their own ends the law was
not there to protect the people of the
country section 5 section 10 and then
there were other sections which we I
became very familiar with section 17
which was to do with association with in
the unlawful organizations these were
the sections used by the military regime
to put the members of the NLD in prison
at any time they felt like it and to
keep them for as long as he wished
section 10 was amended when they when
the time came near for my released three
years after I had first been placed
under house arrest they changed it so
that they could keep me in for more than
that and in fact they kept me in for six
years have you ever heard of a law been
changed
to keep one person longer in prison this
shows you what it meant not to be under
the rule of law while i was in under
house arrest and listening to the news
of the arrest of my rarest of so many of
my colleagues i decided that we needed a
legal aid committee we didn't have any
such thing in our country I don't think
it had ever been known so the moment I
was released after my first term of
house arrest in 1995 I explained to our
party that we must have a legal aid
committee the person I chose to head
this committee was then the chairman of
our NLD you janu who used to be the
commander-in-chief of the Burmese army
and he was a trained lawyer he took up
door after he was expelled from the army
I asked him to form this legal aid
committee to protect those of our
colleagues who were charged for under
some section or the other but all these
sections were just an excuse for putting
them away for keeping them out of active
politics and when I put the suggestion
to luton knew he was not he was he was a
very well he still is a really good
professional soldier he obeys orders in
a very straightforward manner and he
always looked upon me as assets what he
used to call his commander so when I
said please would you had the Legal Aid
Committee he said yes but months later
he told me that he didn't believe in it
he said yes and he took on this job
because I had asked him to he did not
believe that it would do any good
because he said we would never have won
any case when we were trying to defend
our colleagues who had been charged with
fraud charge under Section five or ten
or any of those other very questionable
sections but I explained to him that I
knew we would probably not be able to
win the freedom of our colleagues once
they had been arrested
but first of all I wanted our people to
be to be confident that they would not
be abandoned that they would be defended
as far as possible in accordance with
the laws of the land and secondly I said
that all these cases would remain on
record and that was necessary for the
future these cases of lack of rule of
law would be there forever on record for
future generations to see what they
should avoid he accepted my explanation
but and he he showed no indication
whatsoever that he didn't really think
it was it it would have any positive
results but later he admitted that he
was wrong the heart that we put into our
colleagues they all knew that they would
probably not get away with it that we
would not be able to obtain the release
but they were happy that somebody was
there to stand up in court to defend
them which had not been the case before
we found the Legal Aid Committee a few
of our brave lawyers had come forward to
defend prisoners of conscience to those
charged under those various sections but
we had never won a case and we didn't
win any cases of the thousands of cases
that were taken up by a legal aid
committee we won only one one single
case and the judge was a woman I don't
know whether this is any significance
but I must also add that after she had
passed judgment freeing our prisoner she
was sent off to a remote provision
provincial town as a punishment for
daring to do justice by us so we learned
as we went along that without rule of
law our people were never going to be
free from fear they would always be
afraid that even if they had done
nothing wrong action could be taken
against them in accordance with the
so-called laws of the land so the
importance of rule of law was made known
us through a daily experience many of
our people in those days were arrested
for such small matters as the
distribution of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights this was
considered very dangerous the NLD was
trying to let our people knew what their
rights were because Burma was a
signatory of the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights and in fact at that time
the military regime had come to an
agreement with the United Nations to
disseminate the universal declaration of
human rights as widely as possible so
what we were doing was in accordance
with what the military government had
undertaken to do and yet some of our
people were arrested simply for
distributing copies of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights so for us
human rights and rule of law went
together it says in the preamble to the
United Nations declaration that human
rights should be protected by the rule
of law and we believe that this is
absolutely essential unless there's rule
of law there can be no guarantee of
human rights so when the NLD decided to
contest the by-elections last April we
put forward as a main plaque plank of
our election platform rule of law there
are three main planks rule of law and
end to ethnic conflict and amendments to
the Constitution some have questioned
whether it was right to put rule of law
before end to ethnic conflict we did
that because we think that practically
speaking we cannot bring an inter-ethnic
conflict unless there's rule of law
unless we can assure our ethnic
nationalities that justice will not only
be done but seen to be done for them
they would not be able to support any
peace process with full confidence so we
think rule of law is the first step
towards a genuine Democratic Society in
Burma and because of what we have
suffered we knew from experience that
rule of law is what rules our lives from
day to day and if it is rule of unjust
laws then we are ruled unjustly from day
to day these sections that I have
mentioned earlier sections 10 and 5
should have should never have been
practiced they should we want these to
be removed completely from the body of
our law but this has not yet been
possible we are trying to we are trying
very hard within the legislature but i
have to remind everybody that we are
very small minority as yet to remove
these laws which are misused by the
authorities to deprive the people of the
basic rights you can charge anybody with
those sections when you say that
somebody is a destructive element what
exactly does it mean how do you prove
whether or not I'm a destructive element
but the authorities decided that I was a
destructive element I was a danger to
the peace and tranquility of the state
and therefore I could be put away for
years and years the first time was six
years and then about two years and then
the last time again six years so I was
of course much better off under house
arrest and my colleagues in prison but
the section under which they were placed
in prison section five is equally
destructive of basic human rights
because there is section 5 has a very
peculiar partridge that if you act in
such a way as to diminish the love of
the people for the government but then
you can be charged under Section 5 now
how do you decide whether or not you
have done anything to diminish
somebody's love from something else it's
so vague and it's so broad you can just
pull anybody in this is why we decided
that we would run for by-elections on
this platform putting rule of law at the
very head and after we contested by
elections and we did well we won 43 out
of the 44 seats that we contested we
entered the Parliament at the National
Assembly and since I've been in the
National Assembly the speaker has made
me chairman of the committee for rule of
law and tranquility I know you will
laugh everybody smiles when I say Luke
rule of law and tranquility but it's a
nice thought as a as a practical step
towards re-establishing rule of law in
the country we organized a seminar with
retired judges and experienced lawyers
to find out what we could do to restore
rule of law in Burma I say restore
because once upon a time we did have
rule of law in Burma and some of the old
lawyers spoke the old judges book and
one of them taught about the
independence of the judiciary which we
had enjoyed after independent after we
became an independent nation we were a
parliamentary democracy and the
Judiciary exercised considerable
independence I think if you want to read
about the early history of the judiciary
in Burma you'll have to read dr. mama
who was at Yale Law School
as a fort foundation skoloff a couple of
years before the first military coup he
later became for briefly the president
of Burma after the uprising 1988 but he
did not stainless boats very long in
this study he will you will find that we
did have considerable independence of
the judiciary but with the military
takeover this independence was also
destroyed our old judges and lawyers
wanted us to reestablish the
independence of the judiciary and that
of course is of primary importance
because under the military regime the
judiciary was totally under orders from
the executive at the trial of political
activists the judges quite openly would
wait for a small envelope to put to be
put in front of them they would open it
and in that envelope was be the sentence
that they were expected to pass on the
the prisoners chart and they would pass
sentence we try to teach the members of
our party to to ask those who came to
arrest them what the charges were and
whether they or not they had a warrant
and one of our members just that when
our troop of security officers came to
arrest him he said do you have a warrant
and what are the charges and the man
said don't be ridiculous we've already
decided where the sentence is going to
be so this is rule of law in Burma and
he thought it was perfectly all right
for him to do this and he was simply
trying to let our our man know that he
should not engage in such stupid
activities as trying to get the get the
law to work for him the law only worked
for those in power that was what rule of
lack of rule of law meant for us the law
only worked for those who are in part
for those who are in authority
it is not there to protect the people or
to protect our democratic rights but of
course the military regime did not
believe in democratic rights but now as
the chairman of the committee for rule
of law we have to work in a practical
way to re-establish an independent
judiciary which has the confidence of
the people our people no longer believe
in the judiciary democracy requires a
balance between the three branches of
the executive the legislature and the
judiciary we have hardly a judicial
branch to speak of because it had been
so crushed under the executive for so
many years some of our advisors in that
seminar suggested the best way in which
we could re-establish an independent and
respectable judiciary what we would be
to educate people who would be to be
judges they said one one of the old
lawyer said the reason why we did not
have rule of law in Burma now was
because we no longer had judges who were
well trained in the law and well trained
in the practices of justice this is why
he said there is so much corruption in
the courts of Burma and simply by
producing educated just judges we would
be able to remedy the situation I think
this is too simplistic it is not that
easy to change the ways of people who
have become corrupt over the years
judges who have become corrupt cannot be
changed simply by sending them to
special courses at Yale
they may so it's not just a question of
acquiring a good education it's a
question of attitudes of mindset over
the years not just a judges but a civil
servants in general have become very
corrupt they became corrupt to begin
with because their salaries were
inadequate and in order to make sure
that they would be able to leave decent
lives and educate their children they
started asking for bribes and getting
them now people who get used to that way
of life cannot go back to the old clean
ways easily a civil servant with a
decent salary in Burma and the old days
could live a respectful life he would
have a house he would have a car his
children will be would be able to go to
good schools and he would be respected
by the community in which he lived and
that was enough for civil servants then
but during the years of corruption civil
servants some civil servants became very
wealthy they would have several houses
several cars that children would enjoy
all kinds of privileges and to expect
those people to go back to the old ways
would be difficult even if we were to
give them adequate salaries now the kind
of salaries that would allow them to
live like well respected civil servants
but not like millionaires they would not
be satisfied with it because they've got
used to a different way of life so it's
not just re-education in the technical
sense it's rien it will air with regard
to attitudes and mindset how do we
persuade these people who have got used
to a very opulent way of life that they
can make do with a more modest standard
of living
but need clean lives that will gain them
the respect of society it's very
difficult so their rule of law comes in
again action will have to be taken it's
not enough simply to say we're now
paying you a decent salary you live
within its means they will have to be
laws that will enable else to take
action against civil servants and
against judges who are corrupt so rule
of law will engender rule of law we have
to start by imposing rule of law on the
judiciary itself that is not going to be
an easy task we need help with the stew
dish already has started by
investigating three courts of justice
just to find out what the actual
practices are what do the judges do how
does the government attorney behave and
what kind of Justice do those who come
for justice expect these practical
measures we are taking that we may make
practical recommendations to the various
departments concerned the whole ministry
the defense ministry the attorney
general's office the information
ministry all of these will have to be
involved in our efforts to re-establish
rule of law in Burma if we manage to do
this this would be a tremendous
breakthrough for our country once we can
say that we have been able to
re-establish rule of law then we can say
that the process of democratization has
succeeded until that point I do not
think we can say that the process of
democratization has succeeded it is not
enough just to simply make laws which we
are doing in the ladies
nature we have to make sure that this
these laws are just and not only just
but that these laws are implemented in
the right way there must be due process
as well as just laws so until we can do
that we cannot say that democracy is on
a safe road people ask me have we
reached the point when democracy has
become the democratization has become
irreversible and I say no no because to
begin with the Constitution is in the
way the Constitution allows the military
extraordinary pars and as long as the
military possesses these pars we cannot
say that we are on the true road to
democracy which is why we have linked
these three rule of law into ethnic
conflict and amendments to the
Constitution's these are all linked if
democracy is to be restored to our
country we must have all three without
one the other two will fail to we can't
have rule of law and not have amendments
of the Constitution and an inter-ethnic
conflict and we cannot achieve the other
two without rule of law so because of
these links we put the greatest
importance on the re-establishment of
rule of law it will mean on a practical
basis that our people can be safer more
secure within the laws of the land I am
sure I do not have to explain to law
students that rule of law is not the
same as ruled by law and that laws alone
are not enough they have to be just laws
so Burma is now at the beginning of a
path and I keep repeating that this is
going to be the most difficult road
have to travel to many people think that
there has been a breakthrough I don't
think we can say there has been a
breakthrough we have been given the
opportunity to achieve a breakthrough
this morning there is a word achieve
used a few times and I made the point
that we have yet to achieve we have not
yet achieved but we have been given the
opportunity to achieve and in this
process we need help from different
directions and I would like to take this
opportunity to ask for your help and
support with regard to the establishment
of rule of law in Burma we need
well-trained lawyers we need
well-trained judges we need a good law
school at our good law schools in our
universities we need contact between the
members of our judiciary and the members
of the judiciary's of practicing
democracies there is so much that we
need we need broad education with regard
to write as well as responsibilities
people are very keen on democratic
rights but they do not always want to
know about responsibilities but if we
want rule of law in Burma we must put
equal emphasis on both rights as well as
responsibilities citizens who expect the
protection of the law must themselves
respect the law if we are to achieve all
this then I think we can be confident
that Burma will be firmly on the road to
democracy for years we have suffered
from lack of rule of law which means
that we can never be sure what is going
to happen to us next
this is a fact in Burma for many years
we would have to ask every day who was
arrested that the night before because
the rest were usually made in the middle
of the night and we had to find out in
the morning which of our colleagues were
still free and which had been and which
of them had been put into prison during
the night or taking away to the police
station and often we would never know
where they had been taken in nineteen
898 we formed the committee representing
the People's Parliament that is to say
this committee was supposed to be a
committee representing those who had
been elected in the nineteen ninety
elections which were ignored by the
military because we won too well and
because we declared that they would be
forming this committee many many of our
elected representatives were taken away
into custody they were told that the
authorities wanted to discuss the
convening of Parliament with them but in
fact they were simply taken away to
military cantonments to police stations
and kept there for weeks without contact
with their families they were not
charged under any section of the law
they were just kept their week after
week after week then they were allowed
to come back home I don't quite know why
they allowed them to come back home
every couple of weeks they would be
allowed to go back home and then they
would be taken back back again into
custody and this went on for more than a
year and this was how it was in Burma if
you have anything to do with politics
your life is never secure they can take
action against you in any way they
pleased my own experience at de pelean
deep alien was 2003 when I was
campaigning
in northern Burma and as the campaign
preceded the support of the public
became stronger and stronger and one
evening while I was traveling from one
place to another our car was stopped it
was stopped by a monk who said that he
wanted me to give a speech dusk was
coming on and we had been warned that
there might be problems so we said no it
was too late and there were no
arrangements for me to speak at that
particular place so we would have to go
on but he kept on trying to persuade us
to stop for a bit and then somebody came
running up from the back of our
motorcade and said that troops of thongs
had arrived and they were beating up our
people at the back this was what the
deep alien incident was about some of
those thugs were dressed as monks but
they were obviously not monks because
they all have white handkerchiefs tied
to one arm and think this was to
indicate that they belonged to the same
group and they had enormous stars they
killed four of our people they just beat
them to death and they also beaten the
windows of my car but I had very good
driver we I did not go on because I felt
that I had to wait for the others and I
couldn't just leave them to be beaten up
then the young man who was driving my
car sit look they're putting barriers up
across the road in front of us and I saw
that and he said I think they're trying
to cut us off from our people who are
coming from the other direction shall I
Drive through the barrier so I said yes
drive through the barrier so we can meet
up
well what did you what did you expect me
to do it is it was very exciting i had
never been in a car that leftover a
barrier before but when he got to the
other side we found that there was
nobody there there was just trying to
cut us off from from from all the roads
around us and i don't know what they
intentioned was whether it was just to
beat all of us up or to arrest all of us
but when we got over the barrier we
found nothing and we kept going and
going and going until we go to the next
time when we were arrested now the point
is that we were the ones who were beaten
up but we were put in prison as
destructive elements so this is a great
mystery to us what had we done to
deserve this imprisonment we hadn't
raised a finger yet that was the reason
why I was placed under under house
arrest for the next six years which
threat to seven years because there was
the episode of the American who came
swimming to my house bringing greetings
from all of you no doubt but so I was
kept under house arrest for seven years
the last year and a half that I was kept
under house arrest on the grounds that i
had not turn the visitor over to the
police i had not turned him over to the
police because i did not believe that he
would receive justice from them we had
never received justice from the
authorities and i thought that it would
be immoral me to turn over somebody to
the security forces when I knew that he
would not be given justice mind you I
shouldn't have worried so much about him
because since he was not Burmese he was
let go pretty soon but I was of course
kept on for another 18 months beyond the
time when I should have been released
this I think was basically to keep me
under house arrest while the elections
of 2010 were conducted so the law can be
used in any way that the authorities
please to promote their own political
agenda and that is certainly not rule of
law because of that we are working very
hard in the legislature to reestablish
rule of law and to make sure that it
goes hand in hand with other democratic
reforms if there are no substantial
reforms to the judiciary we cannot
believe that this is a true process of
democratization and I hope this is
something that that you will keep in
mind that you will watch what is going
on in Burma and be aware of the fact
that we have that our judiciary at the
Lotus moment is practically non-existent
and until we have a strong independent
or clean judiciary we cannot say that
Birla is truly on the road to democracy
I'm saying this because people have
asked me when they can assume that Burma
has reached the point and the process is
irreversible and I always say there is
no such thing as an irreversible process
because we were a practicing practicing
democracy when the army took over in
1962 so there is never a point where we
can say this is irreversible but they
must come a point when everybody
recognizes it that to reverse the
process will be far more painful than to
continue along
these reflections on trying to build a
rule of law firm we've asked people to
submit cars and angry I got dozens of
wonderful questions on any of the very
much pertinent to the subject that you
were talking about so with I hope excuse
me if I don't read your question we
there were many duplicated questions and
so I'll do the do the best I can to try
to synthesize the spirit of what I came
forward to in the floor but a good I
thought I'd injured one of the
interesting questions about a rule of
law particularly seems appropriate given
the difficulty of making this transition
from a corrupt essentially lawless well
paper walls but laws that are either
oppressive or not enforced how to make
that transition to the kind of regime
you envision many question is that many
countries around the world in the last
couple of decades have experienced
transitions from having oppressive
non-democratic regimes to greater
democracy do you see any examples in
Eastern Europe or Latin America or any
other parts of the world that have gone
through a transition that seem relevant
or useful to you and thinking about how
to affect the transition in Burma well I
know some examples which tell us what we
must not do I was speaking to some
politicians from Cambodia recently and
they remarked that the fact that we put
so much emphasis on the rule of law was
a good thing they said they had
neglected to do that in Cambodia they
had emphasized the need for free
elections and a free legislature but
omitted the importance of rule of law
and they had said that because of that
Cambodia is now having problems with
taking forward the process of
democratization so this is an if you
like a negative less
and we've learned what can happen
without the rule of law but I think in
other transitions such as in Indonesia
and in South Africa they have tried to
strengthen rule of law as the
democratization process went forward I
think in South Africa perhaps they had
an easier job and we are going to have
in Burma because although there was
apartheid which was which was ruled by
law rather than rule of law at least
there were there were working
judiciary's which I don't think we can
say off in Burma so we'd have to start
from scratch we are in a far weaker
position than many of the countries
which have made the transition to
democracy when it comes to the judiciary
one interesting question asks about the
judiciary and interestingly raises a
number of the things you questions you
did attempt to address like and the
question is what are the major problems
that how how would you so in a sense
rank them corruption of the vishie area
the lack of courage and enforcing laws
against States the competence of judges
the respect for the judiciary by the
people and the political willful reform
and it did seem to be you that's all
that in a way yes of course the home
department that is to say the police we
need a clean police we need the people
who enforce these laws to be to be able
to live within those laws this is why we
are cooperating with the whole ministry
as well as a defence ministry in trying
to re-establish rule of law in Burma we
cannot just deal with the attorney
general's office which I can't just deal
with the courts we have to make sure
that a police two are clean and capable
of carrying out the process of rule of
law seems to me it takes a kind of
political will on the part not only
populus but of the of these people who
are whose lives were abused to a corrupt
regime about the transformative ways yes
it's very difficult to make people
unconvinced and ered of living and it
would be difficult to convince them that
they should take less but on the other
hand of course we can always recruit new
members as well there's there's several
questions here you talked about the how
the question of the rights of ethnic
minorities interweaves with with the
question of human rights in Burma you
want to comment a little more a little
more depth on that I mean what what is
the status of ethnic minority Zimmerman
now and what in the transition to our
democracy how do you see those interests
being properly represented the great
majority of the ethnic nationalities
live in the border areas and as always
happens they can morin justices are
committed the further away you move from
the center of government this is this
happens everywhere and the are people
they are poorer they have less access to
justice they have less access to
organizations that might be able to help
them so unless we can make our ethnic
nationalities feel that they are on an
even footing with the majority Burmese
we will never be able to achieve genuine
harmony in the country the I one of the
request that I always make to people who
want to invest in Burma whether in
development or in humanitarian efforts
or in economic economic enterprises I
ask them to try to work as far as
possible in the ethnic nationality areas
not just to concentrate in that area in
the center central part of Burma where
the Burmese live but in the outlying
areas to bring up the standard of living
of our ethnic nationality States to that
of the central area of Burma and this
would help if there were more
if our national nationality areas had
more access to the wider world there
would be fewer injustice is committed at
least they could not commit pneus in
justices and get away with them to that
extent the connection of ethnic
minorities and religious identity
there's there are many religions
practiced in Burma although the majority
or Buddhist and you obviously yourself
have written about the importance of
Buddhist teachings and practice in your
own thinking in your own life it is are
there how would you what role is there
for better understanding across the
religious boundaries is that a means to
reducing the ethnic inter-ethnic
conflicts some of Isaac nationalities
practice religions other than Buddhism
for example in the kitchen state the
Baptist Church well as the Roman
Catholic Church are very strong
particularly the Baptist Church and in
the chin state as well Christianity is
the dominant religion and i have to say
with great sadness that there have been
violations against their right to
worship freely particularly in the
church and state our chin fans have
complained that pressure has been put on
them to not to give up their religion
but but to practice their religion less
ostentatiously the the Chen's used to I
thought it was a beautiful custom they
used to put up crucifixes on on hilltops
I I think this is beautiful because this
is their religion they worship it and
it's lovely to see them from a distance
but at one time there was a campaign get
rid of all these crucifixes a campaign
conducted by Buddhist and I'm very sorry
that this happened I do not think that
this kind of action should be allowed at
all and the in the kitchen state we have
found the
the Christian churches do very good work
with regard to the internally displaced
people who have been herded into camps
because of the conflict that took place
over the last year we can get help to
them best through the Christian churches
so a lot of cooperative effort is
possible and this will not only bring
about better understanding between the
different religious groups and ethnic
groups I think it is also bring more
practical help to our ethnic
nationalities Buddhist monks played a
significant role in 2007 and the saffron
revolution is our is there any prospect
of that you know using clergy clergy
clergy and clergymen to help cross those
lines I did give an example Tony Blair
taught a course here for three years on
faith and globalization in which the
real focus was was actually drew from
his experience in Northern Ireland where
he is getting a peaceful solution in
Northern Ireland was in large part
because of his ability to work with both
Protestant and Catholic clergy to help
bridge some of the divide I wonder is
that a strategy that could help with
reason I think there are a number of
Buddhist monks and Christian clergymen
who are working towards such as a
resolution of conflicts between their
communities and what's what about the
role of Muslim populations in the Muslim
populations are scattered all over Burma
but of course these days people here
most about the Muslim population and the
rakhine state because of the recent
troubles and their the communal problems
go back a long way and i have to say
quite frankly that these are not going
to be resolved overnight this is another
reason why I emphasize rule of law
because rule of law can help to ease
tensions they will not make the communal
problems go away the communal
differences cannot be made to vanish
overnight it takes a long time it takes
understanding on both sides it takes
positive action from both sides I'm not
saying it's impossible I believe it is
possible because
us there are Muslims in the rakhine
state who have lived there for
generations and at peace with their
Buddhist neighbors so I do not see why
this kind of peaceful harmonious
relationship should not be reestablished
especially now as the government is
saying that they will respect the
citizenship laws I think we should also
go a step forward and review the
citizenship laws to make sure that
they're in keeping with international
standards coming back to sort of the
constitutional framework which you
talked about a bit another question asks
given that the current constitution
provides for sort of reserved
percentages of representation in
Parliament for the military is you see
that as a hindrance to not evolution
toward rule of lard well of course in a
genuine democracy you can't have an
unelected portion of the legislature
which votes on an equal footing with
those who are elected but I have to say
that I really at the moment don't mind
having them the military contingent
there because that's our best
opportunity to get to know them I think
once you get to know us they will
understand that we are not against them
we want to work together with them to
cut built up the kind of society that
would be good for them as well as for us
I've never had so much dealings with
military men in my life until I enter
the legislature have a couple of
questions that go that really go to the
issue of universality versus local
variations so one question is about
democratic institutions I mean do you
see democratic principles as entirely
universal or are is there room or would
it be appropriate to have significant
local variation and similar question
with respect to human rights are human
rights strictly universal or do values
Leafs and different societies were
somewhat different framework for human
rights I believe in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and I
believe human rights should be universal
but with regard to democracy I think
there will be local variations there
will be regional national variations
that cannot be avoided but that does not
mean I accept their kind of definition
of democracy which the military regime
adopted I think they called it
disciplined democracy I think that
simply means yes and in fact I rather
concern that some people still think of
the transition towards democracy as a
transition to its disciplined democracy
that is to say democracy as acceptable
to the military so one area in the realm
of human rights in which there is
actually quite a bit of variation across
democracies is free speech we're in this
country for example could speech is
protected even if it is blasphemous or
criticizes another another person's
religion but in many societies that kind
of speech even though there's general
freedom of expression that that that
kind of speech is not tolerated where
how do you see that under the Burmese
Constitution you are not supposed to
attack others religious beliefs and I
have to say that I think attacking
others religious beliefs is not an a
necessary element in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights you should
be free to practice your own religion
but surely you should respect other
people's religions as well if those
religions do not impinge on your own
freedom I would never insult another's
religion I would never say anything
disrespectful of religions that
not my own because I think that in many
ways that an abuse of my right to
freedom of speech you should not use
your own freedoms to hurt others or to
restrict others freedoms or to offend
others if you do not like what somebody
else is doing because it in some way
infringes on your own way of life then
you can talk it over why can't we have
reasonable dialogue with regard to our
differences why do we need to insult
others because they do not believe in
the way in which we believe one more
aspect of rule of law is has to do with
the world with what can the external
world to to help the advance of ruling
on in Burma and there are actually three
different questions but all pretty much
the same well pointing the same
direction what can the international
community to do to promote the
development of democracy and rule of law
what can the United Nations do and what
can US foreign policy do so your people
thinking along similar lines do you want
calm nth on where can the outside world
be of help well the international
community needs to be aware of the fact
that we need rule of law if we are
really to progress to its democracy I
don't want them to ignore the needs of
our judiciary I think there's too much
concentration now on the economic side
of changes in my country and on the
political side but it seems mainly on
the economic side and we have to be a
little careful of that as I said this
morning a development is no substitute
for democracy and economic development
is certain not no substitute for a week
judiciary so awareness is the first way
in which the international community can
help us with regard to the United
Nations and the United States they could
help us in practical ways with the
training of lawyers with the training of
judges with
I want to set up internships to help our
committee for the rule of law and
tranquility so with the establishment of
such internships there are many
practical ways in which they can help
one our committee and through the
committee the reestablishment of rule of
law in our country well one of the
things the president of Yale can't do is
commit the Yale Law School to any
particular course of action but but I
will have a conversation with our Dean
to see if there's anything we can do to
be helpful on those lines one last
political question then turned to a
couple of personal questions to close so
why did they let you out and what and
why is this transition toward democracy
taking place what was in the minds of
the leaders that allowed this to happen
well we've been discussing this quite a
lot and we tend to forget the 2008
Constitution I think the 2008
constitution was aimed a change the
constitution assures the military and
influential position in the governance
of this country and since that
constitution was adopted in 2008 I think
the military regime felt that it was
time to go forward and to institute the
kind of changes which would bring
positive benefits of the country there
was no doubt about it that our country
had got poorer and poorer under
successive military governments and that
our people were getting more and more
discontented so this is all part of a
program which I believe was decided on
sometime back and 2010 when the
elections were held to turn the military
government into a civilian one that is
to say the the military members of the
government retired from the military and
contested the
elections are civilians and became the
members of this new civilian government
I think most of you know that the
majority of the members of our
government now are ex-military people
the same people who were in government
before 2010 but among them are those who
wish to bring about genuine reform
because they know that the country
cannot go on in this way from from
economic crisis to economic crisis from
social crisis to social crisis and also
I think reform tends to take on its own
momentum and this is what we have to
take advantage of for whatever reason
reforms may have been started we have to
make sure that they are continued in the
right way and that we all help to keep
it on the right path so no fewer than
eight or ten students I think wrote
asked asked a version of the saint of
the following question that's more
personal what kept you going through
those years of house arrest and what
what what kept you focused what what
would you won one form of the question
was what advice would you give yourself
now if you could turn the clock back to
nineteen eighty-eight about how to
endure that hardship or another version
of the question is what advice would you
give to others who are facing a similar
well what advice I would give myself I
could turn the clock back is that I
would have listened much more but I
would have been a better pupil of my
music teacher because really I really
regretted the arse I wasted and when I
should have been practice practice in my
scales and exercises because I thought
if I had rarely studied music very very
well it would have been a great solace
to me throughout the years of house
arrest there were other things I could
do i enjoy reading i had books i
listened to the radio but i would very
much like to have been able to play the
piano really well throughout this year
inner resources that is what is
important what you need our inner
resources to keep you going under under
all circumstances and these inner
resources you acquire throughout your
throughout your life not just during the
years you are at school but throughout
your life and I would say to young
people try to strengthen yourself
internally don't depend too much on
external factors you must be able to
live with yourself I never found it
difficult to be alone there were so many
things I could do well if there was
nothing else I could always think I you
have to learn to do that and also we
have a saying in Burmese what is
important for you is not just to be able
to to what is the word to suffer the
hardships of bad fortune but you also
have to know how to suffer the hardships
of good fortune do you understand what
that means that means that you must not
be shaken by external circumstances you
must not be tempted away from the path
that you set yourself by the hope of
gain by the hope of comfort that you
should not let yourself be corrupted to
be corrupted is to give in to the
hardships of good fortune and you cannot
resist the temptations of good fortune
to be unable to stand up to hardship is
of course not to be able to resist the
hardships of bad fortune so you have to
be able to do for both you have to be
able to detach yourself from the
immediate circumstances and think of the
greater picture you must have an idea of
the sort of person you want to be unless
you have such an idea you will not be
able to hold true to any one path in
life every one of us especially the
young must have an
idea of the kind of person he or she
would like to be I was fortunate in that
very early on I knew what kind of person
I wanted to be this is linked to my
parents I knew what kind of person they
would have wished me to be now of course
it's in this day and age people will
think this is it's very old-fashioned to
want to comply with the wishes of one's
parents but sometimes it's worth a try
you know I had another question which I
think you just answered which is what
would you know what advice would you
give to our students here today as they
face their opportunities to lead and
change the world and I think you've just
done that and so I'm going to say thank
you so much for inspiring us for being
here with us